I joined the 1/6 one project just for
more information as far as in what else
there are other options to do now let's
see an opportunity to get someone else's
opinion and have a different perspective
on growing cane the success of our p16
one is really around being our able to
tailor the recommendations and present
them back to the growers so that they
any doubts about what they're trying to
do is being removed so they can
understand the recommendations are
suited best practice for their
particular farm and then they're quite
happy to move forward and and put them
into place yeah I thought I was doing
everything correctly but I'm with the
one six one program we were just stand
before my fertilizing program hell of a
lot and and just just have this but yeah
I have a piece of morning back here
monitor you're doing it I'm doing
everything correctly to the best of our
knowledge of the information that we got
the moment we can see a big difference
in our property and the work that we do
we Shay is leading to better better
crops better CCS good risotto around
every girl is different and so we work
specifically with what those growers
needs are some girls have needed a lot
more advice on one topic than others so
we sort of try and tailor our on-farm
advice and activities to suit that
particular file in the enterprise we
focus on the runoff that's leaving farms
and entering the reef obviously it's
important for us to focus on what's
going on on the farm and ensuring that
what's being put on with the fertilizer
rate is actually what the crop demands
the main specific change that we've made
by being in the project is dropping
nitrogen levels so far it's been really
good haven't had any problems that we've
conceived by dropping nitrogen rates
quite happy looking forward to what's
going on especially from a financial
point of view as well as anything else
so as well as doing it on farm work we
also like to run a few workshops one of
the main point is to get growers
together because growers learned a lot
from talking to each other the Google
Earth training was useful as we give
each grower a USB in
that's all their farm data we bought
yield maps on their locating of their
soil samples any EC mapping that they've
done and also their actual nutrient
management plan any of the workshops or
programs or or seminars or field trips
they have whatever us try to get to even
if you go to I'm going to only learn one
thing that's one thing you didn't know
yesterday and it's one more thing you
can put in to maintain and sustain a
better crop better farm working with
pharmacist gives you someone else who's
hasn't got a vested interest in selling
your fertilizer and also is on your side
as far as productivity goes the project
gives us confidence that our farm
management is the best it can be and
that as well as working through the BMP
project has given me the confidence that
my operation can withstand any scrutiny
[Music]
you